Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and yeah,
just checking in on you.
What's going on?
How are you?
How's things in your world?
It's almost Friday.
Ah,
today's payday,
right?
You're going to get dead fucking checked at fucking Douche is going to come by
with his gold toed socks,
right?
Poke his head and your cubicle.
Wait a fucking envelope down.
Right?
And he's going to be talking you and you're not going to hear him.
You just going to be sitting this smile.
Or maybe it's a lady.
Maybe it's the web woman.
Maybe she's coming along with their sensible shoes.
You know,
she doesn't have a heel on it,
right?
She's taking it back.
You know,
tell me what to do with my body.
How come guys don't have to walk around in high heels?
Why do women have to ruin their feet and they're fucking lower backs?
You know,
that's like one of those fucking stories that like with this stupid ass fucking
election would actually become like a national story,
some dumb shit like that,
you know,
complete fucking clickbait horse shit.
Who gives a fuck?
You know,
I dunno.
I Dunno how people sit down and watch these conventions my entire life.
I've never been able to get through one.
They are so fucking cringeworthy.
It's so phony.
It's so fake.
The fucking smiles,
those maniacal,
Eh,
like just totally in your head.
You know the candidates at this point,
they have to be completely fucking exhausted.
They don't want to answer any more fucking questions and they still have like
another 90 days of this shit that they have to go through.
You know,
you know,
like when a team goes to the Superbowl,
right?
And you've got the two weeks right before and they just fucking sit there.
All fucking they report is run out of questions and they're just sitting there.
That's two weeks of that shit in those players.
They go nuts.
Just doing that is fucking Kobo over guy fucking my Yana for it's only eight 30
at night.
This is fucking calm over dude in the clam there.
They just keep answering the same fucking questions.
It's going to be easier for Trump.
You know what I mean?
He just has to just make up some shit.
Listening to Trump give his speech is no different than fucking listen to me do
this podcast.
He might as well just be laying there and his fucking underwear is fucking boxes
and just talking to the American people,
just whatever the fuck he's thinking.
He just says it and then like fucking,
you know,
whatever.
20 minutes later somebody corrects him on Twitter.
That APP has been all the time.
Every time I put out a podcast,
somebody goes,
hey man,
not trying to be a dick,
but just let you know.
You know?
You know,
the George Bush thing,
I thought they were just making fun of George Bush dance and I didn't know he
was doing it at the fucking,
it's some,
you know,
the police officer's funerals and memorial service.
You know,
I thought Lewis Hamilton was the upstart driver.
They're like,
no,
it's actually Nico Rosberg since every fucking week I'd do that,
but I'm just some shithead.
I'm not actually running for office.
Um,
oh,
you're not bill.
Thank you for bringing that up.
We didn't fucking realize it.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
yeah,
you,
you truly are a fucking patriot.
If you could sit through those things,
especially this election.
Cause uh,
I see.
I can't fucking do it.
I can't,
uh,
oh my God.
Rudy Giuliani,
God I,
how many fucking was going off Jesus Christ.
What the fuck was he?
What was going on with them?
I love always voice kept going up.
Like he thought the crowd was going to go with them and they didn't really,
they kept clapping,
but he kept increasing his energy and his passion and nothing happened.
At least when Howard Dean got going crazy,
when,
hey,
when he did that thing that he was reacting to the energy,
at least he was fucking connected to those people.
Rudy,
I don't know what he was doing.
Yeah.
I'll tell you the worst fucking image you could ever picture is Rudy Giuliani,
Bang and Hillary Clinton.
I mean,
just imagine that with his fucking that look on his face when he was screaming
about the cops.
And then Hillary when she fucking does that smile where eyes get all wide.
All right,
I'm going to ruin your fucking day.
Picture her bent over.
Put the fucking eyes all wide net crazy smile and hid behind like I jacked guy
guy just fucking banging away.
There you go.
That's on your fucking hard drive.
Now.
You can never erase that.
Um,
oh shit.
Look at me.
They're just there.
It's another one for the MMP fucking Photoshop right there.
I looked for that one tomorrow on fucking,
I guess today,
if you listen to it tomorrow for me on the old fucking Twitter,
Twitter sphere.
Um,
I had such a great time this week.
You know,
not having to go in the fucking writer's room has been awesome.
Uh,
getting caught up in all the shit,
you know,
around the house and all that type of stuff.
It's just,
it's just a fucking,
only being a comedian is the greatest fucking job.
It's the greatest fucking job you could ever fucking half just go on stage,
act like a fucking idiot.
And then afterwards hang out with a bunch of co comics and then you go,
Oh,
then you wait 24 hours,
do it all over again,
apologize for the yarn.
And all of a sudden,
um,
you know,
I dunno,
there's just something about listening to my voice.
It just puts me to sleep.
That's how I got to sleep every night,
you know?
Then I just start talking out loud,
you know,
I'm saying.
And in the rain,
just st 20 minutes later,
I'm,
I'm asleep.
Um,
anyway,
so Monday night,
as I mentioned last week I did a,
I was going to be doing the goddamn comedy jam and a,
I busted out the old fucking John Bonham get up.
And,
uh,
for the first time ever I played my Ludwig 71 green sparkle fucking kit,
add my,
my drum teacher swung by the house.
He tuned the fucking things up so they sounded great.
And I'm like,
I don't know how they're going to sound in the room.
The fucking two year anniversary of Josh Adam Meyers show the Goddamn comedy
jam,
uh,
which is now become a fucking pilot on comedy central.
The show is just blowing up.
So happy for all those guys.
Uh,
they had it at the Roxy down on sunset strip.
Now
you got to understand,
I am a Phi came of age in the fucking eighties.
Uh,
meaning I didn't get laid till the 90s.
Okay.
Um,
anyway,
yeah,
it was a hotel.
It was a rough one for me.
Right.
But basically I'm the fucking,
just the bands that were going on that were,
you know,
the sunset strip was total the fucking hair metal.
You know,
the beginning of the metal with fucking a Randy Rhodes,
you know,
when he joined Ozzy and all,
all those fucking guys,
and then it went into the hair metal and then guns and roses pulled that out in
the end and then fucking,
uh,
who Kay Warren and all those guys,
all of that shit happened on the sunset strip out here in fucking la.
And I used to always read about the whiskey,
the Roxy,
the rain ballroom.
You know,
back when I used to read,
hit fucking per ray.
Anybody used to read hit parade,
a magazine.
I fucking love that magazine,
you know?
Yeah.
They used to put all the curse words in there and everything.
I would,
you know what?
I would actually buy one of those off of fucking Ebay just to read it,
just to see.
I already read about all of those fucking bands.
I knew everybody's name.
I knew the names of every fucking drummer.
I used to watch all the videos.
I used to watch the headbangers ball,
Randy Rockman.
I used to watch the top 10 countdown.
That was hilarious.
It was either like Janet Jackson or some hair metal.
I used to think Janet Jackson was,
was was like fucking pussy music.
But these guys who will wear lipstick and had their hair,
I'll tee stuff like some desperate soccer mom trying to fall in the last dick of
a life.
I thought that that was fucking guide music.
You know,
Britny Fox.
I've always brought that up.
The girls school,
all that Shit,
you know.
Okay
poison.
Every rose has it's thorn,
all of that Shit.
Right.
I got into,
I was into all of that.
Then I started working in a warehouse and uh,
I worked with these fucking burnouts that were,
they weren't burnouts,
they've smoked weed,
but my world,
that meant you were fucking burnout out back then,
you know,
cause back then that was considered was bad.
If you smoke weed,
it was illegal.
We didn't realize that it actually helped with you fucking memory back then.
We thought that not your memory,
it helps with Alzheimer's,
whatever the fuck that claim and who knows.
Yeah.
You know,
the whole fucking weed thing,
it's,
it's like the global warming battle.
I just,
it's going to go back and forth and back and forth.
And then eventually booze bags like myself will finally give and be like,
all right,
you guys were right about the we kind of way people,
all the corporations finally went like,
ah,
you know what,
Eh,
global warming is happening and it is because of us,
but a,
you know,
it's too late to fix it now.
Um,
so I started working with these guys and they,
uh,
played in a band and like I came from more of a jock town.
Right?
Everybody just fucking played sports or you just,
you know,
I don't know.
Stood in the corner on a fucking wall during a party,
you know,
it was basically it.
Those are your only two options town I was in.
And uh,
these kids were from a couple towns over and everybody over there and play
played instruments and these guys came,
I worked with them.
They were playing guitar and they playing the shit that was on the radio.
And I didn't,
I,
I didn't.
They were all my agents and he could fucking get that.
Good.
That's amazing.
And that's right.
Then when I bought my first drum kit,
it brought out I was 20 years old when I started playing fucking drums.
I haven't done everything late in life.
I was always fucking,
I had day late and a fucking dollar short.
Right.
And,
um,
I had this,
I bought a five piece Slingerland kit at the time it was,
I bought it in 1988,
I think,
and it was like 10 years old.
It was all Bonham sizes,
but it was more like the five ply once.
It wasn't a three ply shelves.
So it was,
they were already starting to fucking make them too heavy.
But,
uh,
it was,
black and it had a,
Oh God,
I can't remember the fucking sizes.
It was,
Whoa,
it had an 18 inch floor,
Tom,
a 24 inch kick.
And then what the fuck was the rack?
I think it was like a 13.
It was really weird sizes.
And then later I ended up,
I went down to Al Drewes,
this shop in Woonsocket,
Rhode Island,
I believe that's where it was.
And I found a 16 inch floor Tom,
which was fucking unbelievable.
That matched my kit.
Even the badges said Niles,
Chicago,
Niles,
Illinois.
Sorry.
MMM.
And
you know,
there was no fucking Ebay back then.
I didn't know he,
there was no way to track down all of this shit that people had lying around the
house.
I just went into that place.
They had all these old drums and they happen to have that and I fucking bought
that.
Yeah.
Dang.
I was nine by 13,
10 by 14,
13,
14 and 18 and a 24 kicks.
So then I got the six 16 inch.
So now I add,
um,
I had a six piece kit,
which I thought was the shit.
Then I got some Roto,
Tom's put them on the other side of the high hat cause I was watching Alex van
Halen cause it was all about having the biggest fucking kitchen could possibly
have.
And then along came out guns and roses and a guy named Steven Adler and he
showed up a little four piece kit,
right rack,
Tom floor,
Tom and his fucking ride sitting in between the two,
which was just shit.
And he got more music out of that.
Then half these fucking guys with double bass drum kicks to Tom's above each
base drama,
two floor toms.
Right.
And um,
okay.
That just completely changed my life.
So long story short,
I used to always read up on all that.
I try to do,
I'll try to figure out how to spin the sticks,
all of that shit.
And back in the day all I could do was watch MTV and try to figure this shit
out.
Or You just listened to the records.
And we had an even better than the kids in the 70s because there was no fucking
MTV.
Maybe he caught him on a,
I don't know,
Dick Clark fucking show with some shit.
So,
but all you stab you hear about was,
you know,
if you wanted to fucking make it in rock music back then you had to be down
there.
So here we are,
fucking almost Jesus Christ.
30 years later,
I finally get the fucking go down there on a Monday night and I got to play
drums at the Roxy was,
was fucking incredible.
And I sucked.
When we practice,
like on Thursday,
I sucked on Sunday and then during sound check I was only okay.
And I was like,
God damn it.
I had all these friends come it down and go,
wouldn't you fucking know cause you know I hadn't played and played since March
and I'm a comedian,
so I already sucked even when I was playing.
And uh,
so went out,
did my set,
dressed his fucking bottom and I sat down behind the kit and I don't know what
happened.
I just took it,
I don't know,
just kind of Ah,
fuck it.
Right.
And I ended up playing for me.
I played great.
I the most fun.
I was the loosest that I've ever been at a,
it was fucking hilarious of playing
the song.
And uh,
Dave Cushner who,
uh,
does the music for a f is for family and also was in velvet revolver.
He was playing the song too when he always,
you know,
fucking around and shit makes me laugh.
So I had this stupid fake mustache glued to my upper lip.
Eddie was making me laugh and I knew I couldn't smile.
It was going to come off.
So then half of it was fucking flapping.
He started laughing and then the thing literally floated off my face and we're
only halfway through the first song.
And then I had this stupid bad Dan around the fucking John Bonam wig.
That thing came off.
Then the hair was in my face.
I look like the chick from the ring and my sunglasses started fogging up.
So it's funny,
I was,
I was on a green sparkled kid dressed as John Bonam when we were playing ACDC.
None of it made sense.
So of course it was,
you know,
working,
cause you know,
we just fucking around.
So then we did highway to hell and in the end that was the encore.
We did highway to hell.
And then everybody,
we are bringing everybody out.
Bert Kreischer,
um,
who fucking destroyed.
He opened,
he did a red hot chili peppers.
Give it away now.
And not only did he come out just wearing the sock,
he talked to everybody in the band into doing that.
Um,
I was not out there for that.
And,
uh,
then Margaret showing up,
she fucking killed it.
Uh,
Harlan Williams saying eyes without a face.
He fucking killed it.
And,
uh,
then Ron white went up and sang Leonard skittered get me three steps.
I hope somebody took video of this shit.
So I had to follow all of that.
And uh,
fortunately,
uh,
it was a great crowd.
And uh,
so anyway,
so in the end they brought everybody out to sing highway to hell and they kept
me on drums.
By then my hairs,
that wig is in the face.
I can't see through the fucking sunglasses.
And in the end they just wanted me to keep doing like the symbol wash thing as
the introduced everybody,
you know,
another round of applause for everybody and I forgot and I couldn't see.
So I kind of stopped playing and I kept hearing the guitars.
It was a cluster fuck,
but it was hilarious and a,
I want to thank everybody that came out and um,
I have to tell you that's the best sounding fucking drum kit I've ever played in
my life.
26 inch bass drum.
And the way my teacher,
uh,
tuned it up and the way they miked it up,
it sounded fucking unbelievable.
And what I loved was everyone in the band was saying how great the fucking kid
sounded.
And uh,
I dunno,
I have to figure out,
I swear to God I have to figure out a place where I can just set that fucking
thing up.
That's the goal.
That's what sucks about having a fucking does no place to play.
When you play drums,
you have a fucking guitar,
you can turn down your ramp is no way to do it.
And you know,
it was fun as those electronic kits are,
I know I'm just talking drums on this,
but who gives a shit?
I barely ever talk this much about drums.
They got these drums.
Like if you live in an apartment,
right?
The way it goes,
if you still want to play is you buy a set of v Drums,
all right?
Those are the best electronic drums as far as I'm concerned,
that are out there.
You buy that mid level one,
so it's not that much money.
There's always ones used on Ebay.
And then what I used to do was I would put foam down on the floor than just
build the little two by fours and plywood.
Just build a little drum riser,
okay?
Put carpet on that form and then another layer of carpet.
Okay?
And then you put the drums on top of that,
and then what you do is you go downstairs and you meet your neighbor.
You tell him,
hey,
I played drums.
I'll only play during,
this is what I used to.
I say,
I'm stand up.
I worked nights,
all right,
I'll play during the day.
Only Monday through Friday if I'm going to play.
I played during the day.
If whatever reason,
if you're ever home during those times,
here's my phone number.
Just call this number and I will immediately stop.
I mean that's,
that's just the best you could fucking do.
I told this story before,
then the guy ends up being a cunt,
you know,
one time out of the 5,000 times I played,
he ended up being home sick or some shit or he had a vacation and he called up,
right.
I pick up the phone,
I'm like,
hello.
And he just goes,
can you knock it off?
Okay.
Like right out of the fucking gate.
Yeah.
And I was like,
all right,
Jesus,
quite I was,
I was younger then.
Now it would have been like,
dude,
hey.
Yeah,
you don't fucking say that.
Like you said it to me 50 fucking times.
You can't,
I gave you my number.
I couldn't be any nicer.
Right.
I'm going to stop,
but go fuck yourself and please call me again if I bug you.
And I would have laughed at them and I would have left it at that.
But anyways,
um,
yeah,
three Olli is,
is you're not playing drums if you're on an electronic kit.
I can't explain it.
It's weird because if you play an electric guitar,
you really playing guitar.
But there's just something about those electronic drums.
I Dunno.
I think,
I think most dramas would agree with me.
There's something that you play.
You can sit down on electronic drums and you're like,
I,
how have I not fucking toward the world is one of the greatest drummers of all
time.
This sounds,
I sound incredible on this fucking thing.
And then what happens is then you sit down,
bind a real kit and you actually have to make the sound happen rather than just
fucking hidden somewhere on the pad and getting a nice snare sound or fucking
bass drum.
Then all of a sudden you get on a real kit.
You're like,
oh,
that's right.
That's right.
I'm not one of the greatest drummers of all time.
It's the exact opposite.
I'm one of the worst fucking drummers that ever fucking lived.
This is an embarrassment.
I should be on an electronic kit cause at least so she could turn down.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
okay.
I can't stop thinking of how fucking unbelievable those fucking drum sounded.
I'll do they sound,
it's so fucking good in,
in between.
We played if you want blood and then when they bring in everybody out,
like
I was just,
I,
I still had to keep playing them.
They sounded so fucking good.
Play to that beginning beat to in my time of dying back bed to do well but don't
get it.
They just found it.
Oh the son of fucking amazing.
That's killing me.
I swear to God,
I swear to God.
Why the fuck did I build a gym out of my well,
cause I didn't want to be a fat fuck cause that'd be hilarious if I built a drum
room instead and I put those things out there,
nobody get hurt.
And then I did work out and I got fat and I started looking.
You ever see those awful pictures of John Bonham when he had the fucking wife
Beater on Jesus Christ and he's like 27 years old back then.
Like people just looked so fucking old.
I don't know why.
I don't know what was going on back in the day,
you know,
like they just showed that fucking lunatic,
that fucking lunatic.
John Hinckley who shot Ronald Reagan.
Okay.
Shod.
Brady in the head totally altered that guy's life.
Quality of life.
I forget how many fucking people he's shut.
They just let that guy out and oh,
by the way,
he was obsessed with Jodie foster cause he kept watching her and taxi and uh,
yeah,
I think she was like 13 years old in that fucking thing.
Yeah,
let's let that guy out that,
that's a good thing to do.
Jesus fucking Christ.
The guy's been in there for 35 fucking years.
What's he going to do?
You're going to go go work at one of those yogurt shops.
I mean what,
what exactly is
the guy has no fucking resume.
Okay.
You,
you don't do,
you can imagine
that guy's fucking resume.
What it must be like.
It would just be like,
all right.
He,
Mr Hinckley,
let's see here in a c was 25 when he got arrested.
1980,
81.
Let's see.
So let's just say,
let's say he was a go getter.
He got his first job at 16.
So he would have had nine years on his resume.
That takes us back to about,
uh,
about 1972,
let's see,
in 1972,
a,
you had a job stocking shelves in a grocery store.
He did that for a couple of years.
Uh,
you got a job at a bowling alley.
It's going to be all 70 shit,
right?
And uh,
then you shot the president
and then there's a,
what's it 35 year gap.
Okay.
Shot the president.
1981.
And now you,
uh,
you want to work here at staples.
Tell you what,
we're going to put this in the bin.
I'm going to have a manager look at it.
I want to thank you for coming in and not,
no,
don't,
there's no reason to contact us.
We'll uh,
we'll get back to you as soon as we can.
I don't understand that.
Okay.
This is what I think they should do.
They should fucking transfer it.
Hinckley to wherever the fuck John Charlie Manson is.
All right.
Then you stick them in side by side cells and then they just host a reality
show.
You don't.
Neither one of them is seeing the outside world for roughly the same time.
Whatever Charlie Manson's got like 10 12 years on it.
But at that point,
once you up to 35 fucking years,
you know,
Oh,
I've been in for 47 years.
That doesn't fucking make a difference.
All right?
You just have just fucking talk locally,
locally and just have him talk about just,
you know,
random shit.
You just show them a video.
Give him a little glimpse of the outside world.
Hey,
Charlie Manson.
What'd you think about lady Gaga is meat dress?
You know,
whatever the fuck's going on in the world.
I don't know.
All right,
that's a bad idea.
Okay.
It was that a good reality show.
We've taken some of the most infamous criminals of the past 50 years,
stuck them all in a circle of cells and your eyes won't believe what happens
next.
Um,
you know what's funny is I could probably get to at least a second level of
pitching that show strong interest before the whole thing fell apart and they
realized like,
well,
wait a minute.
How the fuck are we going to get transferred this guy to the other prison.
Ah,
the overhead's too high,
you know?
All right.
There's always a moment with every podcast where it goes off the fucking rails.
And I'm going to go out on a limb and say,
it's this moment right here.
This is the moment right now where I wonder what the fuck am I gonna talk about
next?
Do that guy 60 fucking years old now.
He spent from 25 to years old in a fucking nuthouse and they're gonna if they
gonna let him out.
Now
we're fucking job.
[inaudible] is a 60 year old.
Yeah,
you got any yard computer skills.
He sitting there.
Now what are those?
I mean those giant things from the $6 million man now.
Now they're like,
dig you.
They wait like fucking three pounds.
Now.
You know,
he probably thinks it's a plastic book.
Um,
I don't know what they said.
They're going to fucking try to monitor this guy.
What the fuck is wrong with it?
I just,
I don't understand it
or understand that.
I think it is another thing too.
If you're going to fucking give a guy 35 fucking years,
just put them out of his fucking misery.
Right.
Wow.
What would you rather do?
Would you rather spend 30 years in a 35 years?
25 to 60 no one had 60 you getting out or they can give you the old right there.
Fred,
you know your choice.
I think I choose a firing squad fire to go out.
Fucking get electrocuted,
you know?
Or have you put me down like some old collie with little fucking injection.
I don't want that shit.
Who would want that?
I don't
just fucking have me in front of a firing squad.
Right?
Hey can we not the face just fucking center mass.
Boom.
Done over.
All right.
Here we go.
Did I mention,
I can't remember cause I started this podcast a couple of times here that I
mentioned.
I got some new dates coming up.
Okay.
I've mentioned the European dates.
I got some new dates coming up that are going on sale this Friday and I'm very
excited about this because these are the shows.
These are the shows that I'm doing is I'm getting ready to do my fifth hour long
stand up special.
Very proud of that.
My five year five special anniversary.
Okay,
here we go.
I got to make update coming up,
coming up.
Hey,
it's coming up.
Um,
this is in Huntington,
New York at the paramount theater.
Wednesday,
September 7th is a 7:00 PM and 10:00 PM show.
This is the makeup show for that show that I canceled a due to weather out on
long island,
um,
earlier this year.
Back in January,
I believe.
I'm finally making that one up.
And then on September 8th,
I'm in,
uh,
at the Charleston Galley Yard Center in Charleston,
South Carolina.
September 10th,
I'm in north fork,
Virginia.
It Chrysler Hall.
Uh,
September 11th,
Sunday,
I'm in Richmond in Richmond,
in Virginia,
Virginia at the Altria theater.
And then,
um,
let's see,
the next weekend I'm swimming with great white sharks.
I'll tell you about that later of Jesus getting over a fear.
Stupid Thursday,
September 29th,
I'm in Madison,
Wisconsin at the Orpheum theater.
October 1st.
Holy fucking shit.
Okay.
Does that say all Maha Nebraska?
It's just going to be my triumphant return to no,
I have not been in Nebraska since.
Yeah.
Since I was always doing college cakes.
I don't,
I can't remember the last time I was there.
The Orpheum theater.
Okay.
That's going down on October 1st all right.
This is when we're getting down to crunch time.
We're getting closer to the special Thursday,
October 6th I'm in Atlanta,
Georgia at the Fox theater Friday at top.
October 7th I'm in Gainesville,
Florida.
All right.
What the fuck?
What a God damn Yankee like me be doing down in Gainesville,
Florida and Friday,
October 7th.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
boy,
out to tell you what.
Yeah,
that's because on October 8th the Lsu Tigers are playing the Florida gators down
there on the swamp.
I cannot fucking wait to go to that game.
Uh,
I love both those programs and a,
I've always been a dream of mine as a sports fan to always to go into that
stadium before they tear it down.
He gave him some new flashy new one that,
fuck,
it looks like everybody else's.
I just want to see the layout,
like that whole section of that weird wall where it just says the swamp.
Like what the fuck was that one of those multipurpose stadiums that they,
they used to be able to spin it around and to make it a baseball diamond.
And then after awhile it just broke and they said,
fuck it.
It's a football field.
I have no idea.
But I want to go see that.
A very unique looking stadium and their fans are fucking awesome.
And a as it's SCC football.
And then from a Saturday,
October 15th to Thursday,
October 20th I'm going to be in Washington DC at the national theatre.
Now what's great about that is,
uh,
I'll be doing probably a couple shows at night.
Oh,
it's a theater.
Oh No,
actually,
no.
Maybe I'll just be doing one at night.
I don't know what I'm gonna be doing,
but I'm,
that's the crunch time.
I'm working every single of Saturday,
Sunday,
Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
doing a little residency,
I believe is what they call before I get ready to do my special.
And,
um,
I never write my shit down and this time there's a few things that I think I'm
actually gonna try writing out and then improving on it and just seeing how it
goes on this special just to try something different.
You know,
I'm always trying to do something a little different.
Kippy giving you the same old bill every fucking special.
Right.
So,
uh,
I'm very excited about that.
Uh,
I'm ridiculously excited about the,
uh,
European tour coming up,
not excited about the long flight and um,
you know,
the lovely Nia will not be going with me to those fucking shows.
I'm just doing it cause it's a thrash.
I mean it's all right for me cause I get that they at the high doing the show,
but she's just going to be getting fucking,
hey,
you like this city.
All right.
Is another one you every fucking day.
I think that would get a little old,
but uh,
so any who um,
I think that's it,
right?
Does that my little half hour did I do my little fucking penance for the week
here?
Huh?
Oh,
I'm seven seconds underneath.
Um,
thank you to everybody once again,
they came out to the goddamn comedy jam and thank you to Josh,
Hannah Myers and all those guys for letting me,
they get to play at the Roxy Dude dressed as John Barn and plaintiff's 71 Ludwig
at me fucking,
you know what I mean?
That's,
it's,
that's some shit.
Someday when I'm fucking old and I'm staring at the wall still drinking,
of course I'm going out like Peter O'toole,
right.
Still fucking drinking.
I'm just going to have the greatest smile on my face just thinking about shit
like that.
Like I fucking did that.
That was so much fucking fun.
And uh,
it was just great.
I will do that show as long as they fucking do it.
And uh,
so that's it.
And um,
yeah,
that's it.
Now I'm off to Ireland next time I talked to you.
I don't know when I'm going to be,
I don't know where I'm going to leave me,
lady.
I think I'm going to be over in a,
I think I've already done the three dates in Ireland.
Maybe or maybe not.
I Dunno.
All I know is I think I drive from Bristol to Manchester,
England.
And if I have time,
I have to pay my respects that John Bonham's grave and I have to do it in a row.
I got to do it.
No fucking selfie.
None of that bullshit.
Uh,
you know,
tried to do an a class he fucking way.
You know what I mean?
I always,
I remember because I went to Elvis' house one time and I just felt bad.
I went there to actually laugh,
like,
oh,
get a bit out of this.
And I went to his house,
Graceland,
and I just felt bad.
I just felt like I was intruding on the guy's personal life and,
uh,
not what they had like a gift shop across the street with like Elvis cuckoo
clocks.
Like that guy's one of the most exploited fucking entertainers of all fucking
time.
I mean,
the guy's been dead for almost 40 years to still making money off his fucking
image.
Um,
then in the end,
you walk by his grave in the back.
It's just like a bunch of people just walking by and yammering and saying dumb
shit and that just the sound,
a fucking flip flops and poverty just walking by.
It was just bad.
It's like,
wait,
what are we doing here?
What are we doing it?
They're like an Elvis said the three TVs cause the elites the lock to watch all
the fucking games and the TVS are all fucking out of date,
but she knows something.
When I went in there into his house,
I really saw how fucking like,
yeah,
this must have been the only place that this guy could go to escape how famous
he was in.
He must have been really nice for him to be here and just be able to chill and
relax.
And it's just really fucking ironic that this place that was so peaceful for him
is that we're all traipsing through it.
I'll try to stretch our heads and look up to the fucking the upstairs so maybe
you can see the toilet that he fucking collapsed from,
you know,
it's really bad.
All right,
I guess I'm going to end on that.
Right.
And I commend anybody who really honestly sits there and watches these
Republican and Democratic National Convention.
So at this point,
if you can actually sit through there,
I didn't watch it,
but did,
uh,
did the fucking guy there?
MMM.
Bernie Sanders.
Did he,
did he
just completely flip flop and endorsed Hillary?
Is that what he did?
I mean,
just how can I just,
nothing I just don't understand is how you can sit there watching somebody in a
debate,
trashing somebody and trashing,
have been trashed from trash them saying why they think they're going to be
awful.
And then when the person they say is going to be awful beach them,
they then just do a fucking 80.
It'd be like,
I think this person that I said soft is going to make a great president and as
my full endorsement.
MMM.
So anyways,
all right.
That's it.
I'm done.
Yap.
And uh,
that's it.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm still fucking buzzing off that fucking show Monday night.
I still can't believe I got to fucking do that.
So cool.
So fucking cool.
That's it.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
Your constant.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
All right.
Fucked up.
I got a couple of reads I've got to do here.
I didn't see him.
All right.
Uh,
club.
Gabby daddy owns a ranch.
Um,
innovative concept.
I'm going to,
I'm going to pick this copy here.
Have you ever been in the wine aisle at your local store?
Just staring at the massive selection of wine with no idea which bottle of booze
to choose from?
Most of us go with the bottle that has the best looking label and hope that it's
going to be good.
Well,
the days of playing Russian roulette with your wine selections,
although,
because the club Debbie looking out for the terrorist is a revolutionary new
wine club that takes the class,
the guesswork.
Sorry.
Out of choosing your wine,
they have a simple six question pallet quiz that will match you with delicious
high quality wine.
You weren't guaranteed the love.
The best part is that it club Debbie remains with Dick Cheney will actually ship
your wine straight to your door.
No more going to the store and being lost in the wine aisle.
Love wine.
We've got the perfect wine for you at club dead.
Said Donald Broncho Club.
Debbie is a revolutionary wine club that delivers high quality wine straight to
your door.
They partner with the innovative wine makers from all other all over the world
to produce a wide variety of,
of small,
lot handcrafted wines for their members with club Debbie,
she damn tried to kill him a day.
I'm going to go,
here are all my weapons of mass destruction.
You have the freedom to pick up and choose the types of wine and the number of
bottles you receive each month.
The best part is they offer a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee on every
single bottle.
Bottle.
Start drinking personalized wine selection today.
Try Club death when a dance,
I don't care if it's a fee.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
Now,
where the fuck do people go get this?
Okay.
Is there anything here?
I don't know.
Okay.
$20.
Write code right now.
Uh,
club w was offering listeners $20 off your first order when you go to club
Debbie at.com/birth and it gets even better.
Uh,
I know you hate paying for shipping and all that shit.
So Act so club,
Debbie.
Well,
I'm kind of passing lane and an aquifer will actually pay for your shipping on
orders of four bottles and more.
So it takes something off your to do list.
Join club w.com/burr to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's club Debbie and.com/burr.
All right,
last one.
Uh,
no.
Let me just hit stop here.
All right.
What is it about buying a mattress that leaves you feeling violated?
Um,
is it the pushy people,
the fake presidents' Day sale or the fact that you know you'll regret what you
bought as soon as you walk.
You do the walk of shame out of the mattress store.
Those days are over thanks to he likes sleep where you can buy a mattress
online,
customized view for hundreds of dollars instead of thousands.
Okay.
Thousands of fuck pays $1,000 for a mattress.
Geez.
Some high quality whore,
right?
They're going to helix dotcom.
First answer a few simple questions and he likes true.
Alex creates your custom sleep profile of build you the perfect mattress.
The result,
our customers report 30% improvement in their overall quality sleep.
You're match this little arrive at your door and a welder week up.
It is 100% free.
Uh,
you have a hundred nights to try it on.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free,
grow and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
It's like it never happened.
Yeah,
Jesus.
Uh,
if you do love the new Elyx mattress,
keep it and your dignity.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes and talking about headaches,
sleep.
Go to Heelys sleep.com/burn and get $50 off your order.
That's heavily sleep.com/birth.
He likes sleep.com/bar
was holding.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Hey,
what's going on?
This is below par.
It's the Monday morning podcast and this is the third attempt at trying to be
remotely amusing musing on this thing because a,
I've been on vacation the last week and um,
to what?
Happy and I'm too relaxed.
Had a great time down there and talk at one of the,
uh,
one of the whitest places on the planet.
It's not that,
it was funny,
I just literally had to pause when I said one of the,
what is things,
because someone of color was coming by and for some reason I thought that it was
going to be viewed as racist.
Like I was actually going like,
yeah,
it was really white.
It was awesome.
It was actually,
it was so white.
I believe my level of whiteness was actually offensive,
if you can believe it.
And uh,
yeah,
very.
I can't explain the welfare.
It's,
I don't know.
I was staying out in Wisconsin,
which is even more snooty than a Nantucket.
But,
uh,
if you ever get out there is a little a tip I'll give you,
take a trip of the
fucking brewery out there,
the hell,
the name of it.
Uh,
Cisco,
Cisco brewers and make their own beer,
wine and vodka out there and uh,
go on their website.
If you're a big vodka drinker,
cisco.com I believe,
but just look up Cisco Brewers,
CIS.
See,
oh,
I'm telling you this shit is smoother than grey goose.
It's,
it's unbelievable.
I guess the island's sits on an aquifer.
The amount of times people told me that in the last week at just some point,
it would come up.
Uh,
you know,
this island sits on an awkward for,
and like you,
I was like,
what the fuck is an aquifer was on vacation,
so the fuck wasn't there.
It was more like,
oh,
and what might an aqua Fairbury be?
Evidently,
uh,
you know,
I don't know what it is.
I was going to go on the Internet and I was going to look it up,
but as far as I could tell from the drunk people and their boat shoes,
and they're a tiger woods shorts,
they was saying that a Nantucket was formed from a glacier.
And Somehow,
uh,
I don't know what sits on fresh water in the water,
trickles under all kinds of bedrock and shift from Massachusetts and shift that
just really killed the cleanness of the water.
They fucking comes from Massachusetts and shit.
It's like really fucking clear.
But it,
yeah,
it goes right underneath the ocean.
And I guess it comes right up.
And,
uh,
that's how they make their pod cut tastes so good.
I learned that the trick it all my life and I had no idea that the cleaner the
water,
the smoother and more pure your,
uh,
your heart stuff is.
So maybe that's why all those hillbillies and make a moonshine up in the
Appalachian trail,
you know?
Yeah.
They've talked to somebody,
not 10 people I know,
who've,
who've walked the Appalachian trail somehow got Lyme disease and uh,
you know,
I'm all up for an adventure.
But when you get like a disease that they did an episode about on little house
on the prairie,
you know what I mean?
Basically some 1800 shit,
You get,
Hey,
it's,
I'll look the other way.
I mean we've all la put the gun to our head,
you know what I'm saying?
That's how modern disease,
but you get like typhoid fever for the plague.
Okay.
What's fucked up man?
I was reading this book on the population and uh,
I think I talked about this.
I can't,
I can't remember last week I was doing podcasts from a bathroom in this cabin I
was staying at,
cause it's the only place I could get some sort of cell phone service.
But through reading this book about population
and basically I think medicine,
medicines,
what really fucked us over.
A lot of people think it's dumb people fucking and creating more people.
That's really caused the population problem.
But it isn't.
It's smart people giving dumb people penicillin that has caused the population
explosion.
And A,
I can't stress to you enough,
having traveled as much as I had truly.
How many people need to die in an avalanche for us to ever save the polar bears?
I know.
What the fuck I'm talking about going to God Damn Sunburn on my brain here.
All right.
Now if you're new to my page,
man,
I've got a big thing coming up here.
Uh,
I was saying last week,
my special was coming out on August 23rd.
They just moved the date.
I have my own one hour stand up special coming out on comedy central on August
31st.
All right.
And,
uh,
it's called,
what do I do this?
And it's actually coming on after one a day and pokes specials,
which is great cause he has like 9 million fans.
So if a third of them hang around,
it's going to be a great thing for me.
Um,
yeah,
August 31st and this week my CD comes out.
We'll be in stores,
uh,
have the same name.
It's basically a CD of the specialists coming out on 31st and it's September,
the DVD will be coming up.
So look for all that in stores.
I'll have more information this week and I'll be putting something up on my
website as far as,
uh,
they give you all that information.
But let's get down to the podcast questions because my flight's going to be
leaving here soon.
My flight to Charlotte and then on to La.
I don't know why I got the connecting flight.
Seemed like a good idea.
It's something stupid.
All right.
A bill with all,
uh,
the latest postings.
What the fuck did my laptop just doing?
What are you doing?
How did I hang on?
You know that when you try to click on something and then it selects it and then
just starts going 90 miles an hour down the page.
All right,
bill,
with all this posting of late of a spontaneous crowd members heckles and
interruptions,
it's getting me wonder about,
wondering about a couple of things or I butchered reading that question that
basically saying in the last month I put a couple of postings on youtube and on
my myspace page of people yelling out random shit during my shows.
Uh,
her question is,
you seem,
or his question,
I don't know who sent this.
You seem to be pretty nice generally to these people,
even if they're being a dick,
but I'm sure that's always,
that's not always the case.
Have you ever offended someone to the point of them trying to fight you or made
someone cry or something else really awkward?
Um,
actually,
you know what,
the two people heckling me,
the lady going,
thank you.
And the guy who's in the crowd who was blind,
neither,
neither one of them will be in malicious,
which is why I wasn't being malicious back to them.
You know what I mean?
That's Kinda how I work.
If someone's being a dick to me,
I become a nuclear to them cause you have to out get them.
You know what I'm saying?
It's weird.
You've got to be,
you got to go 10 times meaner than they're ever going to go.
You know what I mean?
It's like that untouchable.
They bring a knife,
you bring a gun,
you know,
they make fun of you fucking head.
You talk about their mothers,
Regina cancer or something.
I know it's disgusting,
right.
But I,
you know,
I don't make the rules.
That's how it works.
All right?
You want to change the standup world.
You go do the late show,
you go do the third show,
Saturday night and the middle of fucking nowhere.
And you tell me that vaginal cancer does not seem like a viable means of self
defense.
I'm not wishing that on anybody,
but I'm not above bringing it up
and wishing it on a crowd number.
I Dunno.
And it's hypothetical,
mother.
All right.
That was brutal.
Um,
anyway,
so you've ever offended someone to the point of them trying to fight you?
Uh,
yeah.
I had one girl chase me around the state and one time and uh,
I didn't know what to do,
you know,
cause she was abroad and if I hit her I'm going to go to jail.
Which is a funny thing about that,
you know what I mean?
It's like they getting up there and they got a glass and they want to smash it
over your head.
You know,
I'm not trying to be a dick,
but at the end of the day that is,
you know,
the average woman is,
weighs over a hundred pounds,
you know,
upwards of 150.
You know,
the average brought out there,
you know,
they got some,
uh,
titties.
They might be pushing one 60.
Who knows,
right?
You start swinging the glass.
You know,
I never took a physics class,
but you can really fuck somebody up.
But for some reason,
because they have a vagina cancer free,
of course.
Um,
all of a sudden now I have to stand there.
There's really,
there's really no way to get out of it without looking like a tool.
Either stand there and you let some girls smash you over the head
and be,
you run away and you look like the biggest fag ever.
Or see you blast them in the face and uh,
you know,
then you look like,
you look like a wife beater rather than no.
There was another adult who they,
rational brain who was,
you had a glass,
which is considered a,
is that attempted murder.
If you smash you,
I know if you smash a bottle over,
somebody said that's assault with a deadly weapon.
I do know as is if you bumped into somebody with your car,
I learned that.
How the one,
I'll tell you that story here in a minute.
Basically what happens is lady came up on stage so I didn't know what the fuck
to do.
So I just picked up the mic stand and I put it between her and myself sort of
alligator arm that didn't have it extended way out because that would seem to
hostile.
So I kind of had it,
you know,
I didn't want to have it up against me because that would defeat the purpose.
So I kind of had halfway,
you know,
so it was like I was extending an olive branch in a way,
and I basically backed up in a circle and she was so drunk.
She kept following me until,
uh,
let me see.
I think she got tired.
It was danger fields where it happened.
And of course there's no security there,
so they probably just sitting there laughing and their ocean's 11 ways to cloak
from waist length,
red coats,
math.
Fucking,
why am I even trying to be funny here?
Too Fun to relax.
That'd be funny.
Next week.
I already forgot the story that I told you I was going to tell you.
Jesus Christ.
Let me go back here a second.
What the fuck is,
I was talking about being on stage,
somebody chasing you all the car thing,
but that's all right.
What time?
I was in a car.
Right?
And that was driving.
Isn't that unbelievable?
Yeah.
I know.
I'm living in an amazing license driving down the street.
And,
uh,
I put on my left directional to get into the left lane.
So there's this lady in the left lane,
but there's enough room for me to get in.
But she does the Kentucky thing.
She stomps on the gas.
Right.
So,
you know,
try not to let me in,
you know what I mean?
And then drives,
you know,
to basically cut me off.
She doesn't let me.
And so when I get behind her I'd be better.
So she beats at me.
So I'm like,
what the fuck I'm right.
You cut me off.
I'd be back at her.
And then she just snapped.
She just slammed on the horn and held it all the way up to this red light,
which is like a football field away.
She just went like,
Eh,
like a half a mile staring at me.
I could see her BDI staring at me in the rear view mirror,
came all the way up to the red light.
And the second she stopped,
I just be real quick.
I went just to piss her off just so I get it last,
you know,
the next thing you know,
I just see her reverse lights come on
and she fucking,
she backed into the front of my car really lightly and I'm like,
what the fuck is this girl doing?
And then I see are reaching into the glove box and I was like,
oh my God,
she's got a gun.
And there was somebody behind me so I couldn't get out.
And I'm not gonna lie to you.
I panicked.
I didn't know what to do.
So she jumps out of the car and you know,
I rolled down my window like a crack because I'm so scared.
Right.
You know this,
this psycho lady.
I'm like,
what's your problem?
She ended up having a pad and a piece of paper and she wrote down my license
plate number.
Then she jumped in the car and she drove away.
Unfortunately somebody saw it and they said,
hey,
was it a friend of yours?
Cause that's how lightly she hit me.
I said,
no,
that was some psycho.
And the person gave me their business cards,
which I kept.
So because I'm a fucking Moron,
oh,
I just completely forgot about it.
And next thing you know,
I'm on the road and all of a sudden I get a phone call.
Yes.
Hello.
This is a officer's shepard calling from the Elsa Gundo police department
investigating a,
a hit and run possible assault with a deadly weapon.
Basically what she did when she backed her car into my car and then said I rear
ended her.
Um,
but I had the business card so I was able to get out of it.
And,
uh,
you know,
who knows,
who knows what would have happened,
you know,
I could have gone to jail and uh,
some would have tried to rape me and then I'd have to kill him.
And then I'd be like Tom Selleck in that really bad movie,
you know,
that's why I like Shawshank redemption.
That's the only one with a dude actually.
They show what would happen if an accountant goes to jail.
You know,
he doesn't start lifting weights and somehow take over the jail.
Now you know what happens?
He gets fucking raped and he gets raped for years.
And that's why you always want to have a fucking alibi,
okay?
Especially if you're having a bad marriage.
If you're going through a tough time,
whenever you go out,
always make sure you got a friend with you,
okay?
Because if you don't,
someday when someone does you the favor of lacking that fucking chick that
you're sick of a,
they're going to blame it on you.
And then you know what?
You're going to get raped repeatedly.
Um,
unless you're good at math,
you know,
and the wardens a piece of shit and your shiny shoes or whatever the fuck that
plays out.
I don't know.
Look,
all I know is this,
I got a special coming out August 31st called,
why do I do this?
Please do me a favor.
Tell as many people as you know,
and even people you don't know,
just bugged people.
Just tell them to watch.
It's August 31st buy cds coming out this week,
August 31st comedy central.
And then,
uh,
my DVD comes out in September.
I don't know why it's happening like this,
but that's the way it's happening.
So please watch that and then come out and see me cause I've already written a
whole new hour cause cause I'm a shit.
That's why I'm at the shit.
You know who's getting killed on fucking,
I'm on my way to be in the shit.
I'm trying to be the shit.
All right.
That's why we're not,
that's the real reason why I wrote another hour.
Actually that's not the real reason.
The real reason why I wrote it because I'm so fucking paranoid.
Once my material,
it has been out there that you know that's a big nightmare.
Being onstage telling a joke and having a whole crowd going,
you already did do and TV fuck and then I just started bombing and then somehow
it spreads across the Internet.
No one ever goes to my shows again.
I got to move back in with my parents.
Then again I'm working in a warehouse again.
I'm loading trucks,
you know what I mean?
Catastrophizing,
I believe is the thought process.
Okay,
I'm going to wrap this thing up.
I'm going to be at a,
the comedy works.
These are the gigs in August and we'll get the comedy works in,
uh,
Denver,
Colorado,
uh,
starting this Thursday.
I think that's July 31st through a Saturday night,
August 2nd.
And uh,
go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com to get all the information.
I'll be at the Miami improv somewhere around August 12th.
I don't have a fucking dates in front of me that they sitting right there in the
myspace page.
You can say it.
And then after that,
I believe I'm doing,
I'm doing the stress factory in New Jersey,
New Jersey.
Sorry,
I got the hiccups now.
Um,
I'm trying to think of like,
I remember any more podcast questions.
Somebody asked me a great question.
I didn't copy it,
but it was a copy and paste it where I can read it right now.
What the fuck was it had something to do.
What is the most overrated thing ever saw in your life and what do you think is
the most underrated?
And uh,
that's too big a topic.
Just come up with one answer.
I'm going to answer even more of it next week.
But the shit off the top of my head that I could say was the most overrated shit
of all time.
Uh,
let's see,
Josh Hartnett the strokes.
Tony Manda rich and he old sports fans out.
They remember that guy.
The incredible bulk scale was an offensive line and they put him on the cover of
sports illustrated.
I Dunno what they thought he was going to fucking do,
but,
uh,
he didn't do it.
Uh,
what else was overrated?
Same.
Not,
not being famous.
Just that TV show fame.
Everybody seems to love that show.
Bruce Springsteen.
I don't get it.
I don't fucking get it.
You know,
the guy sells at giant stadium 19 times in a row.
So a,
it's gotta be me,
but I'll tell you,
I don't,
I don't get it.
I don't fucking get it.
So I guess that's not an underrated,
that would be what?
How about a good,
here's a good one for you guys.
Why don't you guys answer me this one.
What's the most popular thing that everybody was into it then you didn't get,
okay,
I'm not,
I'm not trashing Bruce Springsteen like he's fucking in sync or a boy band.
You know what I mean?
I'm talking about like,
like you know those fucking plastic.
See through cogs that everybody seems to be wearing now.
Crocs,
you know I don't get it.
Can one person to wear shoes like that?
It's fucking Mario Batali.
Okay.
And I'll let you can make pasta to the well method.
He shouldn't be wearing those pocket.
Thanks.
Okay.
I didn't care if you're on hell's kitchen,
just the worst fucking show on TV.
I just can't believe the widows.
People sit there and they let that guy yell at them.
It's bad enough you got to go.
Yes chef.
You know what I'm saying?
But you want a war or something?
Fucking guy.
It makes tuna tar tar.
Get over yourself.
I ever had a child.
We just allowed themselves to be yelled at by a fucking chef to that level.
That kind of looks like an Inchcape.
Bobby Kelly.
I know Bobby Kelly losing weight.
You guys should go and coverage.
And by the way,
look great.
Last time I saw him this,
I'm looking at the after picture of Bobby Kelly Walker by that he will get to,
cause I have faith in them.
Um,
what else the fuck was I talking about?
Oh yeah,
the shift that everybody's into that,
that I just,
I just don't
let them get,
you know,
I'll tell you something that's really fucking underrated.
Water
water's really underrated.
Water's one of the most underrated things of all time.
There is no reason for coke,
soda,
these fucking sports drinks,
electrolytes and all that shit.
They,
they did just drink some water.
I'll tell you what else is underrated.
If you eat a banana and apple and an orange and then later on day you just have
a house salad,
you will be as regular as a fucking race horse.
How these stupid shows on commercials,
they giving people pills,
at least fucking old people.
You know,
it was bottled down working anymore.
It's like if they would just eat some fruit,
you know what I mean?
He's been fruit and then have a fucking salad.
And I'm telling you moon river,
any flesh fans out there?
Um,
what else?
What else is fucking a,
I'll tell you.
You know what?
I'll you,
the one thing that ever lived,
lived up to the hype was the Ipod.
The iPod is one of the few things,
you know what I'm saying?
They never lived up to the heights.
And speaking of hype,
I'm going to see Batman this week.
And uh,
as far as I know,
he's ledger lives up to the high plan,
uh,
playing the joker.
I think it was fucked up.
Somebody had the amount of people who came up to me with theories as to why he,
oh,
because people thought he'd killed himself rather than he sort of took the wrong
stuff the wrong time.
You know what I mean?
Rung them out.
You know,
he told me,
he goes,
you know,
like,
you know what?
I know why.
I don't know why.
I know why he killed himself.
He was,
he was losing his hair.
Can you fucking believe that it was one of the dumbest?
They're like,
like he couldn't affair of like,
he couldn't,
he couldn't afford a fucking hair plugs.
I'll get one of those John Travolta wigs.
You know what I'm saying?
What would you shave your fucking head?
Take a nod from me.
You know what I mean?
How would you kill yourself?
You know,
I just,
I don't,
I don't buy that.
The guy didn't kill himself.
He just,
unfortunately,
I don't know what happened.
I'm like,
I'm going to try to act like I'm trapper John m d here,
you know,
which I'm not obviously haven't even played a doctor on TV,
have I?
No,
I haven't.
I like it.
I like how it only took me eight seconds to run meant and we threw my whole
fucking acting career.
Um,
so anyways,
what time is it here?
Oh,
Shit.
All right,
my plane's going to be born here in a few minutes.
Um,
once again,
uh,
thanks to everybody who came out to my shows in Pittsburgh,
please,
everybody watched my special on August 31st called,
why do I do this on comedy central?
Uh,
my CD comes out this week,
I believe on August 4th and fifth.
Uh,
try to find that in stores and um,
you guys really seem to be liking these random videos that I've been making a
different kind of tape and every step that I do and if,
uh,
if I'm basically is what I'm going to do is if I buy just go off on a risk
that's kind of specific to that city or if I have a good back and forth with
somebody.
It's a great way to give you guys some new laughs without me having to burn any
material.
You know what I'm saying?
Yo.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
You guys all have a good week.
Thanks to listen to my podcast and I'm working on a new website and I will be
putting all of my blogs up there.
Okay.
That's why I haven't blogged in a while.
I have been blogging,
but I have not posted any of them because,
uh,
evidently the Facebooks,
the myspace and the fraudsters,
they own anything you post up there,
they own.
Like,
I can still make a book of my blogs,
which is what I'd like to do.
But so can they,
and uh,
you know,
I don't like working for free.
I don't know about you guys,
but I don't like doing that.
So you know,
I'm just going to start the whale blog on my space from here on out is I will
just put something,
you know,
hey,
I wrote a blog and then I'll just put a link to my website.
That's how I'm going to do with,
because uh,
yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm blogging,
blogging from me,
blogging and make you guys laugh.
I'm not blogging to give fucking Rupert Murdoch some more free content.
All right.
And that is it.
You guys all have a good week and a,
I will talk to you later.
Please go out and buy my CD and stores this week.
I believe it's August 4th.
I really wish I had the date.
I don't fucking know.
August 4th to August 5th.
Just look forward.
Why do I do this in stores?
Tell me what you think then that keep those podcast questions coming and let me
know.
Uh,
let me know some of the shit that you think is overrated or you think is an
underrated.
And the one thing that I dunno,
people are just totally fucking into when you're not,
which might be the same thing as saying something's overrated.
I Dunno.
They go,
why don't you
send me the definition of overrated too?
All right.
So I see them through a crystal.
Hey,
he's a sweet sound,
bouncing around the never ending coal,
the crystal
bouncing around the room
or
bounce around
[inaudible].